bodybuilding is not dumb
at all I think bodybuilding is great
okay I think it's cool to have
competitions and but man imagine that
your life dude isn't that crazy I think
if you're a bodybuilder and you you get
to the point where you're so big and
you're looking at and you're like I
really need to work on this one area
right here and it's like a 10 by 10 inch
section and you're just at the gym
trying to work that one area I I think
that you
have to if you're so focused on the male
physique you have to start
[__] guys oh I didn't know that's
where you were going I think that it has
to be done usually and I don't even mean
in a gay way I just think they got to be
like like a dominance I gotta [__] eyes
but but most of them I would imagine are
driven by more like an over a higher
amount of testosterone than other men
okay so I would have I would that leads
me to believe that that would be the
opposite of true
[Applause]
are like less of that population is
probably almost but isn't it also the
same though being super not gay is gay I
don't know why dude I [__] shut up I
know I know you don't like it but you
gotta give credit to where kids do don't
you
wow oh [__] dude
what you sucked no way like straight up
your a bodybuilder a bodybuilder
times you raise your arms you suck even
more dude that's crazy
dude how dumb is bodybuild
[Music]
ing